cette petite équipe de marcheurs a une
mission bien spécifique sonder les
français sur l'europe
le projet européen est important mais la
réalité n'est pas à la hauteur des
promesses
tout à fait d'accord plutôt d'accord
plutôt pas d'accord pas du tout d'accord
tout à fait d'accord plus de 300 deux
questionnaires ont été remplis en côte
d'or depuis le lancement de la campagne
l'europe intéresse-t-elle toujours on
est quand même fier d'être français mais
voilà on a besoin de l'europe
on a besoin d'être européen le député
didier paris présente lui aussi lors de
cette manifestation entend bien militer
et convaincre les bonds 2019 est une
élection européenne
il faut la préparer il faut que les
français aient conscience mais pire du
pire serait que les français ne se
déplace pas une élection de cette nature
aussi importante pour notre pays et pour
notre avenir
il y avait du sondage sur le marché de
bonnes mais pas seulement on est la
république en marche et ont fait une
consultation citoyenne sur l'europe on
avait les jeunes macro nice tout
également fait du porte à porte pour là
encore sensibiliser et tenter de
convaincre les potentiels électeurs
sincèrement non mais par contre bon je
reste ouverte et je dis pourquoi pas si
vraiment si vraiment ils nous écoutent
ils vont changer des choses mais il va
falloir qu'ils ont changé dans le bon
sens et après je serai convaincu mais
pour l'instant je suis dans la tente
d'après le premier bilan de la
république en marge de côte-d'or
l'opération est un franc succès au total
sur le plan national environ deux cent
mille personnes ont été interrogées